the motion of objects and space is
governed by the universal law of gravity
so let's consider how this works we have
two objects here object one and two and
that could be two planets or two
asteroids or two white dwarfs black
holes any kind of objects you can
imagine and they are mutually attracted
by each other due to gravitation so we
have a gravitational force and we label
this as F and this is the force on
object 1 due to the interaction between
the bodies 1 & 2 and here we have a
force that's that that's a force on
object 2 due to the interaction between
objects 1 & 2 and the objects are
separated by a distance R 1 2 now we
want to derive the universal law of
gravitation how we're going to go about
that well Newton figured out a while ago
that it is proportional to the masses of
objects 1 & 2 so this one has mass M 2
and this one has 1 and it is also
proportional to the square of the
distance between the two objects now we
need to do one more consideration to -
and then we can derive this we need to
actually well first we need to pick some
kind of origin from where we are
considering these two objects to be and
this object here goes from the origin to
there and we call this R 1 and then we
have here are 2 which also means that
the distance here between object 1 & 2
is R 1 2
and actually we know from vector
decomposition that r12 equals r2 minus
r1 so just this minus this gives us this
distance here now if we want to write
down the universal law of gravitation we
also you know there there's a magnitude
component to it and we also need a
direction and we haven't yet chosen a
coordinate system we could of course
choose our usual way of placing the I
hat direction the x coordinate in the X
direction and the J hat coordinate in
the Y direction but when we deal with
the universal law of gravitation it's
actually better to adopt a slightly
different coordinate system everything
in space usually orbits one another so
it's much better to think in a radial
direction rather than just normal
Cartesian coordinates and so in this
case we're going to choose an R hat
vector which gives us a radial direction
and we're going to do this here so this
is going to be our R hat direction on
object two and here we have an R hat
direction to one and we're going to come
back to to the our hat
unit vectors later for now we can just
write here quickly down the definition
for the unit vector so our had one two
is of course the vector itself
r12 divided over the magnitude of the
vector and I can write it like this and
now we can we can write down the
gravitational law so the force on object
we're going to look at object to the
force be on object to due to the
interaction between objects one and two
is proportional to the mass of the two
objects we already said that in the
beginning and
the square of the distance between the
two objects but what about the direction
the direction here we were looking at
object two we placed our hat unit vector
to point down but the force is going in
the opposite direction so on the
negative r12 hat direction
so we have to add a minus here and then
r1 to our hat and as it is the case with
most of these laws as a proper
proportionality constant and Newton
called this capital G and G as we know
today from experiment is six point six
seven ten to the minus eleven and then
in terms of units we have Newton force
goes in Newton we have mass this is
kilogram squared and we have meter
squared so that's that are the units and
if you plug those in then units of the
whole equation will work out so let's
quickly consider the force in object one
to see what's happening over there so we
have F 2 1 equals minus G m1 m2 over R 1
2 squared and in terms of the unit
vector we now have r2 1 hat here going
so again this minus goes with this unit
vector and that one is pointing here in
the opposite direction then all force so
that's all good but what we see from
this one here and actually from our
diagram already that r12 equals minus r2
1 and so we see from this then that
actually Newton's third law every action
has an equal and opposite reaction
is true for this little setup here as
well and because the forces are of
opposite direction and of equal
magnitude